hello everyone
ah
hi I'm Larry gray and I'm going to talk
to you about building strong and
sustainable open source projects but you
should know from reading the description
of this talk it won't be a normal talk
about just open source itself I'm going
to tell you a couple stories quite
interesting and they all center around
road trips right
um
and the reason I guess I'll take a step
back and tell you why this is important
to me so after 20 years of working as a
biomedical scientist
I got introduced to open source and it
changed my life it changed my career I'm
no longer a scientist I guess I always a
scientist but
but I switched careers
and I became a part of a wonderful
community that I was hoping other
projects could adopt and learn from so
but how does this even relate to a road
trip we all have been on road trips
everyone in this room probably been on a
road trip right so but I don't think
you've been on an epic road trip
[Laughter]
it's a
so the Story begins my friend Jacob and
I were finishing our summer internships
at uh university called Cal State
Fullerton
and we planned on at the end of the
summer to take a road trip to Vancouver
British Columbia so we're located down
here at the very end of this map so
we're in Orange County California
and Vancouver is really far north right
and so at the end of the summer we
decided we're going to celebrate this on
this end by going and what we decided to
do uh the hiccup that we had is we have
very little money like we literally had
enough money to get halfway there and
back and so but hear me out
um
we were expecting a paycheck right so
the thought was all right we'll start
our journey we'll get paid and we'll
complete this journey obviously you can
see on the screen it says Fullerton
California to Eureka California we never
made it out of the state of California
foreign
to leave but on the my
simultaneously What's Happening Here If
you see the blue line
uh that blue line is our path to Eureka
and it's up to five freeway in
California The Gray Line is a a route
going up the Pacific Coast Highway right
up there so just happens my parents are
leaving to go on a trip to Portland
Oregon about the same time that we're
leaving
they're going up they get to San
Francisco they're going to take a train
from San Francisco to Portland Oregon
and that was the trip that they're
playing
we leave like a day or two apart from
each other
nothing's going on there so Jacob and I
go in our first stop is San Francisco we
stay at one of our fraternity Brothers
house
um will and we stay there at night and
we get up in the morning and I check my
bank balance
no money right
um and so one thing that we also notice
on this trip is that once we start
traveling we didn't take an account for
food and water into our into our
calculation so we had even less money
than we thought we did and so we leave
Will's house and we're traveling uh
towards Eureka and I'm driving and Jacob
says hey that looks like your brother in
the carbosada so I was like no we're
like 900 miles away from our house
that's not my brother and I look over
it's my little brother
yeah
and so I flagged him down and we're
thinking we're eating beef jerky at this
point that's what we're consuming and my
dad gets out the car and he's just
tapping his watch it's like what and
he's shaking his head and he looks at me
and say Larry it's dinner time and I'm
always serving you'll be around no
matter where I'm at right
because during college the only time I
saw my parents was to go steal food from
them right
um and so they take us out to dinner so
we have food for the night and we take
their leftovers is at that point and we
will not I'd never told the story to my
parents at all and they like okay let's
go back to our hotel room
and I remember my dad asking me so where
are you going to stay at I was like oh
we'll find a place we were going to
sleep in my car
um and so we we get to their hotel room
and my dad goes in he comes back out and
he's kind of he has a scowl on his face
and he's upset it's like I don't want to
stay at this place you know it's it's
bad you know we're going to find another
hotel do you guys want to stay here
it's like
now we have a place to stay
um and so that so we stayed there
tonight and we're outside and my friend
Jacob is smoking a cigarette and we hear
a lot some loud music
it's like okay let's go check this out
and there's a house party going on so
there are people everywhere so we
thought we'd just roll into the house
party and and and hang out so we meet
the host and he's wonderful right he's
really nice we hang out we drink some
food and everything else that we need at
this party we leave at like 3 A.M in the
morning and before we left the host was
like hey come back tomorrow we have a
picnic you can come to this picnic and
it's like okay you know we really don't
have money to leave but we'll do this
um and so we go over to this party and
it's amazing like there are people from
different ethnicities different cultures
there's people uh just really really
amazing
a moment and one of the things that I
remember distinct list someone playing a
guitar someone playing a digitally do
um it was just you can you can't make
this stuff up
um so we stayed there and at the end of
the night he asked the host as you know
do you have a place to stay and we're
like well we had a hotel room now we
don't and it's like stay here so this
goes on for like three or four days like
we're just hanging out picnicking every
day and meeting cool people and
and so we do this
um and then finally Jay was like you
know what we probably need to go back
home you know it's been over a week you
know we're not going to make it to
Vancouver
and so we we had back like obviously
that morning I checked again every
morning I checked to see if we got the
money right
uh but never no no money so we get back
to San Francisco
and we're hanging out with will my
fraternity brother again
and I checked my phone and the money
comes through finally but we're at the
end of this vacation and so we go out
that night and we celebrate not only did
we celebrate I bought beers for the
entire bar
so and here's like here are pictures of
Eureka this is me celebrating singing
so
how does any of this relate to building
strong and sustainable
open source projects there are what I
found to be certain ingredients that
were necessary to build a strong open
source project
so in our in the story we embarked on a
road trip
to Vancouver British Columbia our
purpose and vision were to explore new
places and have new experiences and have
fun so we wanted to take a break from
our internships and enjoy a journey
filled with surprises
right but in order to build a successful
open source project you need to have
clear purpose and vision right this
ensures that everyone involved
understands the goals and the adjectives
and also able to it also allows you to
make better
decision making or guide your decision
making
so that's one of the first ingredient
so as I told you when we're at this
party we met people from everywhere like
it was all
all faiths everything that you can
imagine and that was
it made it the the journey memorable and
it can simply be applied to how we uh
how we want to build our open source
projects and so that they Embrace
openness and diversity so because we
want unique perspectives right and we
also won't Creative Solutions and that's
what diversity uh and openness brings
right
so
be open to unexpected surprises so Jacob
and I had a surprise almost at every
turn of this trip right run into my
family
on the outskirts of Eureka crashing a
party making new friends all of this was
unexpected right but these unexpected
surprises help you grow and evolve as a
as a project right could it could be as
simple as getting new contributors or
dealing with issues right these
unexpected surprises are always good for
for our projects
so
learn from failure and keep pushing
forward so
The Pride we can I think we can all
agree that the road trip started
differently than plan
we were low on funds and had to adjust
our plans accordingly
so but for projects this all means that
you stay focused on your goals right and
you remain resilient
so this is how you overcome your
failures and keep going
and you saw me do this you saw me
singing in a bar celebrating success
together right and this should be your
milestones and or just new contributors
right shared ownership and pride as the
um product of sharing uh achievements so
if you want to
um
make sure that you're working with
people that fill a sense of ownership
and take pride in what you do make sure
you celebrate your successes together
and be willing to take risks who in this
room think I took a risk when I took
that drive everyone
uh
but we didn't we didn't let the lack of
funds or my poor math I'm a biologist
not a mathematician so
um we took a risk and hit the road
anyway so similarly with open source
projects you might not always have the
answers or the resources but you need to
make calculated rest
right
so most of you I think would call me I
have a high level of positivity about me
but the positive attitudes and
willingness to embrace surprises they
were key to our journey right but as a
project these are the things or this is
the thing that will help you build
relationships and overcome obstacles I
truly believe that being positive helps
so we're going to switch gears just to
no longer parallel the the road trip but
just some actual things that you need to
do when you're running an open source
project
build a strong governance model this is
important because it leads to effective
management and transparency in your
decision-making process and it also
builds trust amongst your contributors
collaboration and communication
are also critical
and so you need to create spaces for
discussion so we're Slack
forums what other place is needed in
order to
help you grow and communicate and know
that you're on the same page
clear documentation I thought I would
never say that I was uh all about
documentation
um but until I started working on this
project and I realized there were
several layers to documentation so you
had the user level so you had tutorials
you had you know guides user guides and
things like that to help the user become
familiar and use your project then you
had the contributor guide right to get
contributors into your project and
working so that they can be a part of
your community and then you have code
documentation that helps the
contributors that are there to stay up
on top of things and be able to do it so
this is almost essential for you to have
a successful project that you meet each
and every one of these needs
I like this one I don't know how many
people have been burnt out on open
source but it is definitely real
the way that we combat it at my project
is that we developed something called
semesters
like
three months every three months you can
sign up for a position within the
project
it could be a contributor it can be a
maintainer it could be what we call a
coordinator but during that three-month
period you dedicate your time to that
and you don't have to enroll the next
one like you have no obligation to
continue and work all the time because
that's a problem in open source you feel
that you're alone and you have to work
all the time and keep these projects
going but we built into our our system
is that we're going to reduce burnout by
setting these intentional breaks in the
in the project and it works very well
so
keep an active and engage community
this involves creating a welcoming
environment where contributors feel
value supported and empowered to
contribute
um
and so this Ultima will lead to
Motivation by your contributors
to engage in your work
so now we get to our Second Story
I have two epic stories
so this this story is quite interesting
because it doesn't happen in the United
States but it's about me trying to get
from one place to another
um so I want to take holiday in Tasmania
um Australia
and my plan was to fly into the city at
the top called Launceston Launceston
right and from launch testing I was
going to take a bus all the way to the
um the capital called Hobart right and
along the way I was going to go to the
coastal towns and visit and do this
and so the first day I left Launceston
and I went to a city called Saint Helens
and so at St Helens I stayed at a hostel
and I met this Nepalese guy named Johnny
so Johnny and I decided to go explore
St Helens in the in the nearby stuff so
this is Johnny and me all right this is
20 years ago
um so Johnny and I are exploring things
and we go to Bill Long Bay which is this
beautiful beach uh we hang
we hang out uh all day and we just have
a blast right so Johnny and I get really
close like really quickly like this is
my my buddy right and so I was like at
the end of the day I have to take my bus
I'm going to Hobart nice to meet you
goodbye and it was like brother
it's like yes we don't take the bus
around here what do you like what are
you talking about he said we're gonna
hitchhike it's like
not me so but
I'm easily influenced so
um so we took the we actually decided we
went out to the highway and I put my
thumb out and this old lady pulls up in
a Bentley and offers us a ride
and I'm astonished and it's like this
lady is so trusting and she must feel
really safe right and so we get in the
car and she talks to us and just tells
us about it tells us about her life and
we go down she drops us off at the next
next coastal town
and this continues to happen
all the way to Hope art right so
um we we get the whole Bart and I'm
staying at Johnny's Place
and uh John Johnny and I don't exchange
information I'm thinking I'll never see
this guy ever again he's in Australia
I'm not I don't write postcards I don't
write letters so
um we go to
I fly back to Mainland Australia and I
told a friend it's like you will not I
called her her name's Anjali
and so
Anjali I told her you're like you have
to come to Tasmania I had this amazing
experience they had this community that
had safety trust there was like this
whole entire network of people that made
up this amazing Community right
and so she was like yeah she's like me
and she's like yeah I didn't need much
convincing she's like I'm I'm down so we
go we do the same exact thing people are
giving us places to stay giving us food
you know taking us out on their boats is
everything you can imagine happening on
the trip happens
so
and since she's not here to do this and
we've been friend from France for almost
30 years
I remember feeling such a sense of like
Divine synchronicity in the sense that
we happen to stumble across so many
amazing people and places and at exactly
the right time and exactly the most
auspicious way and so there was
something about that that felt so
special to me about that trip it's not
like we had some elaborate itinerary
planned and were following a detailed
right map or schedule that we had
already plotted out it's like we were
open to possibilities and what might be
available to us and then everything
seemed as I remember to fall into place
so wonderfully and so there's something
about that
um in particular when I look back on
that trip that feels
both unique and also just what a
blessing right like such a so she
remember I didn't make it all up there
was someone else there
all right so Anjali and I go on we visit
places like the blue tier rainforest and
we hang out and do some great things but
the as we are traveling uh down to
Hobart the last person that picked us up
was a college student right and so this
college student offered us when we got
there it's like hey you know you have a
place to stay tonight you can stay with
us and I remember it was late at night
and we were driving and I'm thinking
this place looks quite familiar right
so we get to the house and I was like
I'm sure for some reason this is deja vu
like I've been here before and so I go
to sleep that night I hear a knock on
the bedroom door
and the door opens
Hey Brother
it's Johnny
and so obviously you've
I was at Johnny's his roommate was who
picked this up
and so me being me is like I didn't take
this information it's like yeah
I'm going back to the state so I head
back to the States
and eight months later I was like I
really want to go back to Australia I
wasn't going to go to Tasmania I was
just going to go back and visit some
friends in Australia and this is when
Flight was really cheap so I could
actually afford to go
um so we
I get there and I remember one day we're
sitting at a cafe
um
and I'm just having coffee and I hear
Hey Brother
if I knew is eight months later and I'm
in Melbourne Australia far far far away
from from Tasmania and I turn around and
it's Johnny
so I do take Johnny's information this
time
sadly I lost it
oh yeah
um but that's the
second uh
epic trip
so now how does this pertain to open
source projects I think what we left off
at was talking about having to engage in
active communities there are things that
projects can do in order to have engaged
communities and so I just want to list
those things off so that you would know
if you're on a project you have some
ideas of how you can gain exposure and
increase and or maintain your your
contributors so the first is uh
attend conferences so what you want to
do at most tech conferences you have
open source Sprints you can give a
lightning talk you can get at pycon I
know this you can get an open self wears
Source software Booth so if you're a
beginning project and you want a booth
you can go get a booth right so
give talks at local Meetup so meet
locals and and
the benefit of this is that you get to
meet locals and get project exposure
simple Go to meetup.com do not do what I
do do not join all the meetups
laughs
take your time and get to know each
group
so you can also host community hackathon
so what ended up happening with my
project we were kind of all located in
Washington DC area and so we can meet in
person quite a bit but as the years went
on we all moved to different places and
we needed a mechanism for us to be able
to get together and have that feeling of
of working working all at the same time
so we started doing these Community
hackathons where we bring in
contributors core contributors and
maintainers into a session for like
three hours and we just work together
and it what this ends up doing it
enhances Descent of community and so
this could be in person virtual but
these are ways to stay engaged
so this might be unique
um develop courseware so I'm a Adjunct
professor at Georgetown University and
one of the things that we do for our
data science program is to incorporate
our project our open source project into
the curriculum right and so now we have
students that are champions for for our
project so if you can get the
opportunity you can do this through
University you can do this through
online education platforms but this is a
great way to provide educational
material for your users
so sit on panels so if you ever get the
chance this is a great way for project
exposure and this generally comes as an
outgrowth of participating in the
community in your local community
um
so submit a conference talk
um this is a great way to share your
passion I know that our project we have
plenty of conference talks but it's a
great way to get other people excited
about what you're doing
just select the appropriate conference
and that I tell you that from experience
and review previous proposals so you
know what it's kind of expected
you can start an internship so one of
the things that I truly believe is that
we should be fostering the growth of
others
and we did this through Google summer of
code so we brought in interns to work on
our project and it benefited them as
well as us to have extra hands on the
project
um
when I first started with my open source
project what I did was write blog
articles
we sat around at a big table and we just
start typing and we would we would go
over each one the others work uh we'll
give them ideas and it was all to show
in Practical settings how our project
works in the while and this was great it
was a great exercise for us but it
provided more content for our users and
we've written books and we've written
papers about our project so it increases
exposure these things increased closure
and don't worry this is a lot of stuff
this just didn't happen over so I
started this project back in 2016 right
and it's taken us like eight nine years
to to do all of this so don't be worried
that you have to do all this tomorrow
so I say provide mentorship because this
is quite different than an internship so
I really believe that there's a benefit
to you to be a mentor right you get the
lesson you get to give advice and
you know provide access to your social
network so if you ever get a chance and
you see one of my other talks it's
talking about building Social Capital uh
and I truly believe that helping each
other gain access to the networks that
we have is going to help them and help
their careers grow and that we should
see each other as a community that wants
to help one another and so providing so
today you should definitely introduce
yourself to someone else and connect on
LinkedIn and try to fill out your
Networks
so anyone in the room familiar with
non-focus okay okay
so I'm on the board of numb focus
and it's a great organization it's a
non-profit that
sponsors uh open source projects so if
you're in the python World we're talking
about numpy pandas all these big
projects that they provide some sort of
support
so as a project you can join non-focus
either as an affiliate or as a sponsored
a mentorship membership so this
increased exposure they have small
development grants so if you're trying
to find your your web pages or get web
page design you want to do documentation
you want to translate it to a different
language all that type of stuff can be
paid for through these development
grants they also provide financial
management for bigger projects that
receive grants or anything like that and
it's a great way to network with other
projects so it's just not python even
though I love python
so I there are other projects involved
like Julia as a also another language
sponsored by non-focus
so now let's talk about things that you
should not do absolutely shouldn't I do
not ignore user feedback they're the
ultimate beneficiaries of your project
right if they a user gives you feedback
unless you know if it's feasible and it
makes sense for your roadmap or anything
like that you should definitely respond
and don't ignore them
don't be too restrictive not a lot of
rules not a lot of requirements to be a
contributor that really discourage
people to contribute to your project
obviously don't neglect your community
this is similar in vain to the ignore
user feedback so
what ends up happening if you do this
there's the possibility of losing
momentum and as an open source project
the one thing that you have that that's
really valuable is the momentum of your
project right you do not want to lose
that momentum you don't want to because
uh it's like a S curve right once you
have momentum it grows really really
really quickly and so you don't want to
lose that
and don't forget to plan for
sustainability and this is where
non-focus could come in and help like if
you needed funding to do things so you
should be thinking about this even when
you're little when you don't need money
the sustainability plan for us is simple
we have a board of directors on my
project
we calculate all our expenses for the
year
we divvy it up amongst the eight people
that own the board and we just pay for
it that way right that's our
sustainability plan
uh and it works for us
um and this is
I you should know either I'm a scientist
and from what I've told you you know I
like to experiment so so don't be afraid
to experiment because experimentation
leads to Innovation new ideas
and trying out new technologies is all
important for for this so don't be
afraid to experiment
so now I'm going to talk to each and
every one of you here and tell you that
if you ever thought about contributing
to open source you should do it right
and I'm not just going to tell you I'm
going to tell you the benefits do it
let's talk from a very selfish
point of view like what are you going to
gain from this
um what I gained was I was able to build
software development skills in a low
stress environment like no one
everyone's out there to help you so you
get to learn a lot learn to build a
maintainable project
all right this is a co-benefit and just
being a part of the open source software
Community is a big thing simple submit a
pull request for your favorite project
my project is called yellow brick and
you can you can do a pull request on any
of the Affiliated projects from
non-focus pandas matplotlib
those type of things
so now
the benefits uh have an active and
engaged community on the left hand side
this is a Sprint that we had at pycon
and we had over 30 people in this Sprint
and we did 17 pull requests it was a
really really
[Laughter]
[Applause]
society and plus you get to meet cool
people so I'm the so now the creator of
python which we email quite frequently
with each other now because I met him at
a conference doing exposure work for our
project but this is me meeting him so
you get to meet cool people
all right so and that's it thank you
um
you go go to lawrencegreet.com uh you
the slides are available there for
download and you can just get them there
so any questions
oh oh yeah I'm just wondering um for Num
Focus how much of your time goes into
fundraising and like how challenging
that is uh well I've
we have an entire Opera num Focus this
entire
fundraising team it takes a lot of
effort in order to maintain it
um I would say
a good deal of time is split between uh
hosting conferences and fundraising and
you know as you can imagine it's been
hard Economic Times to get people to
give you money right now so a lot of
effort is still being put into that but
we we do have dedicated staff just that
does fundraising cool does it does it
come mostly from corporate or like
non-profits or so the czi
um I don't know if uh Zuckerberg
so we have funding from NAMM which is a
non-profit we do get corporate
sponsorship depending
um so it just kind of comes from a
little bit of everywhere
yes
did you ever reconnect with Johnny
no I'm sorry maybe he would show up
um so how do you handle like bike
shedding or what basically peop when
people like
argue a lot about stuff that like the
less it matters the more people more
vehemently people argue about it yeah
we've had this discussion several times
um
I I I think for for us
um we have a bit benevolent dictator
that's solved our our problems and we've
kind of we've done it very because
We Trust
it's two actually two we have two uh
dictators and uh we trust them both and
so to get around a lot of those types of
issues we just put it on their backs to
make the final decision on those and
when they disagree
so I think they're kept their
disagreements like behind the curtain
because I have yet to see them disagree
thank you thank you
so there's a lot to do how do you do it
sustainably how do you maintain balance
and keep going
um
use the semester system
really take breaks because when I first
got started I was every if I wasn't
doing my regular job I was doing open
source and quickly quickly burn out from
that so the the answer is to develop
some sort of sustainable system that
watches out for people so that they
don't get into that trial because it's
fun I'm not gonna it's like really
really energizing to be able to produce
something that others will use and
you're doing it because you're just
passionate about it not there's no
external reward that you're going to get
so
yes have you had to deal with
controversial controversial pull
requests like maybe something that is an
interesting idea but like goes against
the grain of the project
well this is an interesting story
so uh if there's anyone joining us from
the UK
um and my project it's a visualization
project where we generate images of
machine learning model performance so
you can just see the performance in a
visualization all right and in order to
call that we would say dot dot poof
p-o-o-f right sounds we're Yellow Brick
sounds like The Wizard of Oz right never
thought about that well
um in the UK it doesn't have the same
meaning
yeah
and so it took a lot to deal with that
because you're like why would I this is
the innocent word why would I change it
uh and also recognizing that it so we
ended up changing it but it took a lot
of conversation to do something like
that so we've enter those types of
instances also
so I can remember the first pull request
ever submitted open source 13 years ago
and it got rejected oh Lots changed
since then
um but what would you say to somebody or
some people in here that are maybe
scared or afraid
yeah
so
what would I this is so weird because
our one of our number one models is be
kind right so if someone submitted a
pull request that just didn't work out I
personally would work with them to
actually look at what it is that they're
gonna what they're trying to accomplish
and figure out a way to make it so I
think I'm like I'm sorry that you had
such a bad experience
um but for those that are are scared
um
try
um simple pull requests right
try something that doesn't involve a lot
of detail just to get get in to know the
maintainers
and so that they begin to trust you
because they also are guardians of this
code base and so if you start off by
submitting very small things they will
begin to trust you and see that and so
that's a way for you to kind of avoid
just submitting a huge pull request and
that they just decide they're not going
to look at it I would never do that I
just
that just does that help
yeah thank you thank you
yes
so yeah I'm still kind of fascinated
about how you kept running into drowning
and I thought it was cool how your
friend thought it might be related to
synchronicity which literally a couple
days ago I just learned about for the
first time it sounds like Carl Young was
doing a lot of research about it but I'm
curious if you have any theories or
hypotheses about what how the odds
happened that you kept running into
Johnny
so I have many more stories like this
so I don't know if I just
in some past life I I did some good
things and I just happened to be able to
do this I really do not know but there
was a a lot of good energy coming from
Johnny like he was a really really nice
person very kind person like as someone
that I would definitely
would like to keep running into right
um so I don't have a good answer for you
about about that my friend definitely
when she recorded that I heard that I
was like yeah that sounds about right
so cool
yes
you have Benny oh sorry that was off
initially
um do you have any words for people who
maybe they've hit the burnout phase in a
project and they don't know how to move
forward with it but they want the
project to live on for them to kind of
manage that away from themselves and
relieve themselves of their
responsibility but keep it alive because
I think we've seen examples where this
has been like big key infrastructure
things
carry so much responsibility and that
burns people out even faster and then
it's even worse when it doesn't go well
when they don't hand it off
successfully
challenging question
um I I guess
how to extract yourself
from a plane that's flying okay when
you're the pilot right is that what I'm
hearing
um
I don't know you know you carry a
parachute
um
and I don't think there's a answer
Beyond trying to prepare the team to to
fill your shoes like I think that's
the answer but you have to make sure
that you're not trapped into that
because what ends up happening even
though you your love for this project is
strong there can be a sense of
um
uh resentfulness that that accompanies
uh this extraction if you're not able to
successfully severed the chord right so
that's my my response
I start another talk I'm sorry
uh do you do you have any thoughts on
open source projects started by
companies or you know
with strong
um yeah I I think
have done properly
um they can be they're quite successful
like they're
um plenty of Open Source projects that
are happening out of this and we're
seeing
um
I don't I guess my thought is f is truly
open right that that's the key word here
is of these projects are closed to a
certain extent that uh because we do see
that we have projects that are open
source in word but you really can't go
in anyone can go in and change the code
so
um my my response would be
I'm all for
corporate open source projects if
they're truly open
all right
yes you mentioned uh finances
there's reimbursement for expenses uh
but there's also like reimbursement for
time
do you do that like I can't it seems
improbable that like we could pay the
people on our project anything like what
what we make in our jobs oh no no even
there is no no way
anyone's getting paid anywhere close so
you're just making sure people don't
lose money when you talk about
sponsorship no for those uh sponsorship
it's
it's fiscal sponsorship which is you
know there's a legal term here physical
sponsorship means something completely
different it means like overseeing
finances because a lot of these projects
are so big they they receive grants they
receive other forms of outside money
from companies and they need a way in
order to manage uh those incoming funds
and so whenever we talk about fiscal
sponsorship we're talking about uh
someone actually doing the overhead work
to manage your your finances
thanks
so
my experience in open source is we have
a pretty distinct problem with diversity
we know that software is already way
more male than the general population
and way whiter and then as you go into
open source it just gets worse
I'm we could probably talk about this
for hours but like why do you think that
is what's your perspective as a black
man
um
it takes a lot of effort and work to
have a diverse project
right so I'm lucky on my project when we
first started off there was eight of us
there was five women
uh a person an an Asian person
uh me
and a guy from Guyana right all on this
team so it was done it was people were
welcoming and brought in whoever wanted
to work right and it was done very
intentionally to uh nurture
people from different backgrounds and
meant extra work sometimes because some
people would come in with not the uh the
skills uh necessary so I meant extra
work
so the reason
I just think overall there's just more
the the population balances are just not
especially here in America right
um they're just not a lot of African
Americans that are doing Tech right they
would like to do Tech so we need do our
best in order to nurture that population
or that pipeline of people in order to
get them more involved
but it's definitely a numbers it's a
numbers game but it's nowhere close to
being uh
the representation of the population
right and so I don't know I spent my
entire life
I'm here because of diversity programs
or whenever I was in college there were
programs that helped they were targeted
toward getting
people from
[Music]
socio-economic dis disadvantage people
uh into PHD programs and it's very
deliberate right and so without those
types of programs being very deliberate
you're going to see this type of
imbalance in between the different
different groups but it takes a lot and
it's not I'm not just saying you can
flip a switch it takes a lot of effort
a lot of effort to do this
does that
sort of answer your question
yeah I'd love to talk to you about it
some more because it fascinates me it
seems like a huge problem and something
that I've had so many benefits myself
from
from open source but I'm I I've had
immense privilege in my life as well
I've had a lot of spare time where I
could spend it coding for free and I
think not everybody enjoys that
privilege and I wish everybody could get
the same benefits I've had from it but I
I don't know it feels like a problem for
the whole of society right
uh we're we're cutting it like he's
saying he's giving me the signal thank
you thanks a lot
[Applause]